but we're going to begin this hour with
the latest on the shocking attack on
Paul Pelosi as you know he's a husband
of house Speaker Nancy Pelosi the
suspect in the assault is expected to be
formally charged later today on counts
including attempted murder speaker
Pelosi was not home at the time of this
attack but she was allegedly the target
a source tells CBS News the suspect
shouted where is Nancy at her husband
Paul after allegedly breaking into their
San Francisco home Jonathan Vigliotti is
following all of this in San Francisco
we have to warn you here that the new
details are still very disturbing
Jonathan this story is still upsetting
on so many levels good morning to you
and good morning to you Gail very scary
moments early Friday morning according
to police a hammer was used by this
suspect to carry out this attack he was
specifically targeting Nancy Pelosi when
he broke into that home early Friday
morning we're told he even made his way
to the second story of that home and the
Associated Press now reporting that
investigators also found a bag at the
scene containing zip ties
across a Scott and Normandy inside the
Pelosi home a source tell CBS News Paul
Pelosi was able to call 9-1-1 after
asking his alleged attacker if he could
go to the bathroom there he reached a
police dispatcher and left his phone on
giving authorities enough information to
launch a quick response from the time
the officers got the call to the attack
was minutes less than three minutes I
believe according to San Francisco's
police chief when officers arrived they
found Pelosi and 42 year old David de
Pape fighting over a hammer de papape
allegedly grabbed hold and used it to
strike Pelosi in the head both men were
rushed to San Francisco General Hospital
where Source tell CBS News Pelosi
remained conscious and able to talk
before undergoing surgery to correct a
depressed skull fracture the Pepe was
treated for minor injuries late
yesterday the San Francisco D.A
confirmed the attack was targeted Mr
depap was in fact looking for Miss
Pelosi the other thing is we want to
make it clear that there were only two
people in the home at the time that the
police arrived Mr Pelosi and the suspect
sources have told CBS News and other
media de Pepe said where is Nancy
echoing the same language used by the
January 6 Capitol Hill mob after the
2020 election
comes days before the midterms when some
get out the vote ads have taken direct
aim at the speaker on Face the Nation
Margaret Brennan asked the chairman of
the national Republican Congressional
committee Congressman Tom emmer about
his gun-toting ad with the hashtag fire
Pelosi why is there a gun
in a political ad at all it wasn't an ad
I was tweeting outside Dr Pelosi with a
weapon well now would your pink slip be
more fitting if it's about firing her
why don't you make it about the issues
why not depersonalize it it is
absolutely about the issues it's about
the fact that we have double-digit
inflation leaving the hospital Paul
Pelosi Jr would only say this about his
father's condition any updates on your
father
far so good so far so good
and according to a source de Pape has
been released from the hospital this
morning he is in police custody he is
expected to be arraigned as early as
tomorrow morning Gail
all right we just want him to be all
right thank you very much Jonathan